monsieur ce que cela mais au pâtis
remboursés par la sécurité sociale
voilà une question qui n'en finit pas
d'alimenter les débats
l'homéopathie est reconnue et remboursé
par la sécurité sociale depuis 1965 en
france mais déjà à cette période
certains médecins ne se gênait pas pour
montrer leurs doutes voire leur méfiance
face à cette médecine douce mais sur les
plateaux télé les défenseurs de
l'homéopathie avait les mêmes arguments
qu'aujourd'hui et les rebelles sur
hambourg celle d'une façon très très
convenable d'ailleurs la sécurité
sociale tout intérêt à cela parce que
les robes aux coupes dans l'ensemble
beaucoup moins cher que les autres
à cette époque ces médicaments sont
remboursés à 65% 65%
c'est beaucoup trop pour les antilles
homéopathie selon eux c'est de l'argent
public gaspillé dans des traitements
placebo dans les années 90 le ministre
de la santé s'en remet à une commission
d'experts pour statuer de l'efficacité
et donc du remboursement ou non de
l'homéopathie
il s'agit de rembourser ce qui est
efficace pour la santé des jambes
au final le taux de remboursement reste
à 65%
mais quelques années plus tard alors que
trois français sur quatre ont déjà suivi
un traitement homéopathique nouvelle
salve de la part de ses détracteurs
nous n'avons plus les moyens d'assurer
thé social n'a plus les moyens de
rembourser des médicaments qui n'ont pas
prouvé de façon scientifique leur
efficacité
et cette fois ci le couperet tombe le
taux de remboursement passe de 65 à 35 %
et les français sont divisés
mais après cette baisse le nouveau
ministre de la santé soutient
l'homéopathie d'abord vous avez c'est
une toute petite goutte d'eau dans
l'assurance maladie et il faut savoir
que 10 millions de français aujourd'hui
consomment des médicaments
homéopathiques
pas de quoi calmer les opposants en 2005
certains médecins reviennent à la charge
réponse du ministre de l'époque xavier
bertrand le déremboursement des granules
une fausse bonne idée selon xavier
bertrand prise de position explicite du
ministre de la santé dans le journal le
monde
cette mesure n'apporterait aucun
avantage financier
mais en 2011 dans une certaine
indifférence le taux de remboursement a
légèrement diminué passant de 35 à 30%
toujours trop selon les contre une somme
minime qui permet un moindre recours aux
antibiotiques selon les cours
cinquante ans après le débat n'est pas
encore terminée
[Musique]